human rights must be the center of our
foreign policy but the way to do it is
not through endless military deployments
it's with our diplomacy oh this pathetic
settled sack of crap my god it's patter
for boobs who don't follow foreign
policy closely and biden knows that
well after joe biden finished blaming
the afghan military for its own collapse
and and blaming donald trump he then
just started saying very silly things so
this i think was the silliest thing that
he said in his entire ridiculous
submission speech here
he said that our enemies
would have been very upset if we'd
stayed in afghanistan
this is
asinine at a level beyond most ascin
entity it's like record levels of
assaninity here is is joe biden i mean i
i
honestly you you lose words
when when you hear things this stupid
it's as though you're being spoken to by
an alien intelligence that does not
speak english anymore except it's really
old and has to drink cans of insure and
it's barely sentient here's our barely
sentient president
our true strategic competitors
china and russia
would love nothing more than the united
states to continue to funnel billions of
dollars in resources and attention and
destabilizing afghanistan indefinitely
oh is that what they'd like interesting
china and russia want us to want us to
stay so what they would really hate is
if we were to leave right that's when
that's when they would be like right now
they're quaking in their boots because
we pulled out of afghanistan and
abandoned hundreds of thousands of
people to the tender mercies of the
worst people on earth and we not only
abandoned our allies and completely
undercut our allies we then celebrated
ourselves and in doing so
probably they like nothing has made them
tremble and quake in their boots more
than this unless it was us abandoning
you know parts of the ukraine to to
to russia or abandoning hong kong to
china the united states over the last 20
years has become very good at abandoning
allies it's pretty impressive normally a
good foreign policy requires you to be a
good friend and a horrible enemy right
now we are a horrible friend and a
fairly good enemy
simple fact okay so here's the thing
this is so easily debunkable
but we'll do it anyway
joe biden says right there that china
and russia wanted us to stay in
afghanistan
and that they would be upset with us
leaving afghanistan weird because china
immediately
seized on us leaving to say that they
will recognize the taliban and will now
work with the taliban to increase
chinese influence in the region via
their belt and road initiative
according to foreign policy magazine
china hopes to get its hands on
afghanistan's trillion-dollar rare
earth's metal they have mountains made
of rare earths over there which is the
rarest minerals for their part the
taliban are already saying they're happy
to work with the chinese and they don't
give a crap that the chinese
are imprisoning a million muslim uighurs
in chongqiang
china's embassy in afghanistan by the
way our embassy is getting invaded
china's embassy is still open over there
so everything is going great with the
taliban with china china has also
solidified relations with pakistan
presenting a solid face against india so
the possibility of conflict with india
has increased
also just to add some insult to injury
the chinese global times which is an
official ccp outlet is an official
chinese communist party at ccp outlet
they tweeted out from what happened in
afghanistan those in taiwan should
perceive that once a war breaks out in
the straits the island's defense will
collapse in hours u.s military won't
come to help as a result the dpp that's
the democratic people's party of taiwan
will quickly surrender
so
yeah clearly they are they are you know
they're very upset that we left clearly
they're already already threatening
taiwan
and this is their goal by the way their
goal here is to threaten taiwan into
basically electing friendly government
the way that it happened in hong kong
they're hoping to do this without having
to fire a shot but if they have to fire
a shot they're really not particularly
afraid of the united states they add a
quote once a cross straits war breaks
out while the mainland seizes the island
with forces the u.s would have had to
have a much greater determination than
it had for afghanistan syria and vietnam
if it wants to interfere
sounds an awful lot like an awful lot
like osama bin laden in the aftermath of
uss call right the united states is a
paper tiger it is a weak horse i can do
whatever i want and the u.s won't do
anything
see betraying weakness on the global
stage is a horrible idea
by the way the chinese it's not just
completely sound and fury apparently
the people's liberation army eastern
theater command on tuesday dispatched
warships aircrafts and fighter jets for
joint live fire assault drills in the
southwest and southeast areas off the
island of taiwan as a response to recent
moves by the us and taiwan secessionists
so china is already militarily
threatening taiwan in order to
presumably get them to elect some sort
of conciliatory government that will
allow taiwan to be subjected to the same
tyranny as hong kong
foreign policy of horrors of acne joe
biden created a vacuum our enemies are
rushing into the vacuum see we can quit
a war it doesn't mean our enemies did
guys
we can quit a war and we can walk away
and we can abandon our allies it doesn't
mean that the bad guys just go away
that is not how any of this works
i know that we've spun into our memories
the idea that abandoning vietnam was a
good foreign policy choice
it only led to the deaths of two million
people in cambodia hundreds of thousands
of people floating off the coast in
boats
that's all it led to
and abandoning iran never had any bad
consequences
and this is this is all just
it's patter
for boobs who don't follow foreign
policy closely and biden knows that he
knows that
all right and he didn't stop there
because it never stops there
joe biden also decided it was necessary
to
gaslight the rest of us
i think my favorite part of this and my
favorite i mean worst is that joe biden
he gives this speech right he gets his
his big surrender speech and in his
surrender speech he then lies and says
don't worry we're still supporting the
afghan people
no i've noticed you're not that's that's
what i've noticed
call me crazy i don't think they feel
very supported right now here is biden
we will continue to support the afghan
people
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid will continue to push
for regional diplomacy and engagement to
prevent violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people of
women and girls
just as we speak out all over the world
i've been clear
the human rights must be the center of
our foreign policy
not the periphery
but the way to do it is not through
endless military deployments
it's with our diplomacy
our economic tools
and rallying the world to join us
oh this pathetic saddle sack of crap my
god
truly truly unbelievable
don't worry guys you know we're we
haven't abandoned the people of
afghanistan i'm gonna say words
and you know what the taliban takes
super seriously verbiage this is their
big thing if you send them a really
pissed off missive the taliban are like
whoa you know when you had actual air
bases here and you were dropping bombs
on us that was one thing but now that
joe biden is gonna say things
the guy who just withdrew and let us
take over he's gonna say stuff and
because he says stuff we've decided
women can go to school again
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid we're gonna send the
humanitarian aid to the taliban how's
that gonna work exactly
our international influence with what
the eighth century cavemen
our diplomacy oh well i mean if we send
a few engraved letters via the us
embassy that no longer exists in
afghanistan
then things will probably be fine
we'll speak out for the basic rights of
the afghan people we'll speak out just
as we do all over the world you know
we'll say we'll say stuff well hashtag
bring back our girls hashtag we stand
with afghanistan
so many i mean there are so many
hashtags
the power of hashtag will emerge
victorious once again that is joe
biden's plan in afghanistan
he's been clear he says that human
rights will be the center of our foreign
policy not the periphery the basic human
right will be for the taliban to come
and just kill everyone that's that's a
pretty big human right but you know
he'll say stuff he'll say stuff when you
know between episodes of matlock he's
got a t-vote he's got like a few minutes
in between to really frame a nice tweet
or more importantly have one of his
aides frame the tweet so he can go back
to sleep and get his sleepy time in
if the lies continued
then he said you know what
we we are we are making sure that we are
evacuating everyone that's what we're
doing we're really making clear that
like our plans are in place we're a
little surprised by how fast this went
but we're evacuating everybody
our troops are working to secure the
airfield and ensure continued operation
of both the civilian and military
flights
we're taking over air traffic control
we have safely shut down our embassy
and transferred our diplomats
our diplomatic presence
is now consolidated at the airport as
well operation allies refugee
which i announced back in july
has already moved 2 000 afghans were
eligible for special immigration visas
and their families to the united states
amazing well a stunning number 2 000
afghans eligible for special immigration
visas and their families have moved out
that's incredible what what an amazing
feat out of a hundred thousand people
a hundred thousand
by the way there are still ten thousand
american citizens in the country
many of them are residents journalists
or aid workers
most are trying to escape the u.s state
department sent out to tweet yesterday i
kid you not in which they said make sure
you file your paperwork properly then
they took down the tweet because they
realized how dumb that sounded
that people are going to be filing their
paperwork to get out of afghanistan as
the taliban take over and start shooting
people
according to the washington post
editorial board the state department and
defense department basically now have
two options negotiate safe passage for
american citizens with the taliban if
possible or send the us military out in
the city to bring americans back to the
airport before the taliban gangs find
them
officials working on these cases inside
the government told me they have no
clear guidance from the white house and
not enough support
also the state department is dealing
with more than 80 000 visa applications
for afghans who worked with the united
states government or find themselves at
risk by the way that is a very low
estimate that's just the number of
people who have applied in the last like
couple of weeks
if they could apply i am sure hundreds
of thousands of more people would want
to get out
in a joint statement the state
department of pentagon said well you
know our big mission is to secure the
kabul airport there yeah i love that
when biden says our troops are working
to secure the airfield you know you
might have wanted to think of that
before you pulled out all the troops you
have yeah dope you might want to think
of it but before you know the afghans
were actually jumping onto the wheels of
planes to escape you might have wanted
to think about all of that that might
have been a thing worth thinking about
the statement said tomorrow and over the
coming days you will be transferring out
of the country thousands of american
citizens who have been resident in
afghanistan as well as thousands of
afghans who are in danger
but even the mission to secure the
airport is going awry says the
washington post on monday u.s troops
shot dead at least two armed men who are
among the masses storming the airport as
monday afternoon u.s officials said the
flights to and from the airport had
stalled
there was one u.s military plane where
the the
people who were staffing the plane that
so many afghans climbed onto like
hundreds of extra afghans trying to
escape climbing on the plane and you
want to talk about actual empathy the
pilots of the plane the staff of the
plane the american military talk about
brave people they said okay we're over
capacity we're taking off anyway they
saved 640 people on that plane
that is what american soldiers do
american cowards act like like president
biden acts
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video